やあ、みんな
はじめしゃちょーの実験室へようこそ
今日はね、君たち野球が好きだと思うんだけど
こちらにピッチングマシーンがある
ちなみに最高速度はMAX165kmまで出るわけだが
まあ今日はね、バッティングセンターっていうのは
まあ行くのが大変だと思うんだよ
うん、大変大変
だから僕はこう何か、やっぱ研究者として
近い将来誰でもね、自宅で手軽にね
バッティングマシーンが楽しめるというね
まあそれの僕が先駆者というか
まあいわゆるフロンティアというかね
そういう先駆者というか
まあ先駆けになれればいいなと思ってる
というわけで今日はね、こちらの
ピッチングマシーンでね
正直怖いんですけど（笑
今から
「部屋でバッティングセンターやってみた」ってね
やってみようと思います
ここから球が飛んできて
で、こう当たるんですけど
で、僕はバッターボックスでこう
まあ場外ホームラン、まあ窓ガラス割れば
まあ場外ホームランって感じでね
やっていこうと思います
というわけでまずはね、こう実験で
球、MAXスピードで今から当てるんで
どれくらいの速度で飛ぶかというのを
まず僕知っておかなきゃいけないんで
命が危ないんで（笑
まず実際に僕が球を入れて当ててみます
じゃいきます
やばいやばいやばいやばい（笑
じゃとりあえずMAXパワーで1回やってみましょう
いまMAXです
やばいでしょ（笑
まあいってみましょう、いきます
いくよ
いきます、いくよ
うわっ、ダメだダメだ、やばい！
うわっ、ダメだダメだ、やばいやばいやばい！！
ちょっとマジで！？
ちょっと待って待って、ちょっと待った
いいよいいよ、回していいよ
こわっ！大丈夫？
じゃあ、1球目
よし来い！
無理！無理無理無理
いや、でもね、なんか掴んだ
今ので掴んだから次で打ちます
うわぁぁぁぁいやぁあ！
ちょ、ダメだ、ボール替えよう
球こっちにします
よし来い！
うわっ！！やばい・・・
うわーやばっ！！ちょっと待って・・・
あっ・・・
うわーっ！
プロ野球選手でも多分この距離は無理だよ
うわっ
速すぎる
あっ
うあーっとと！！
くそー
あっ、当たった！
へこんだ！
ピンチヒッター、ピンチヒッター
ピンチヒッター、よしこ
よしこぉぉぉ！！
よしこぉぉ！(wwwww)